[Musik]
hollywood wasser feuer
murats ernsthaft herzlich willkommen in
nur 85 minuten und zwar heute machen wir
richtig gehen ja als rezept ein männer
rezept das heißt kochen auch die
geringem bildungsniveau und ja auf jeden
fall was ganz ganz einfach es ist könnte
innerhalb von fünf minuten selber machen
und ich habe echt gedacht klar denken
die meisten ist natürlich klar der murat
kanntest weil er seine frau hat mir gut
backen und kochen kann kann jetzt
natürlich auch deswegen wollte ich
einmal zeigen dass es wirklich auch
menschen gibt
da vergessen was ich sagen wollte auf
jeden fall kommen auf geringem
bildungsniveau
dazu habe ich den kinder eingeladen juni
kann spiele kommt genau das auch jeder
von euch weiß dass es auch mit nicht
jeder hinkriegt habe ich in wien geholt
weil der könig kann nicht viel aber das
kann man gut
zum ersten mal war der grüne jetzt kam
immer noch zusammen im bad und wir haben
eigentlich die wand tapezieren müssen
wie sie gekommen ist und gesagt hat wir
sollen was kochen weil sie was im kino
machen will
jetzt kommen einfach ja aber wirklich
schön wird würde schon wieder aufhören
so herab und wir sind auch nicht unsere
schauen dass ich guck mal wie sie sagen
dass sie mal ich hab meine schütze nein
gerade noch
doch das ist deine chance für mich hat
es noch pink mache ich nicht weil ich
mich ohne männliche schütze die hatte
die kinderschützer ist eröffnet und
seine crew ich noch habe die passt
warum nachschub richtige schraubt sagen
nicht in die augen zu bekommen ist
irgendwie sie ist aus
okay auch wenn wir haben noch zeit
lieber gummi und wir werden jetzt was
kochen angeht ich auch interessieren
können aber ich hab gedacht komm machst
du halt ja auf jeden fall man fange mal
mit den zutaten und zwar ich schaue auf
einen teleporter um einen teleporter
sagt mir 250 gramm butter 60 gramm honig
und 200 milliliter milch bo milch von
der kuh dann haben wir hier um das ding
schaue mich zu schlagen was schlagen da
ist schaut man sich das ok drei eier die
schlagen wir schauen dann haben wir hier
52 gramm zucker und hier haben wir eine
prise salz zu glauben machen ok und da
haben wir auch einen teelöffel man den
extra dann haben wir für den teig haben
wir hier nüsse und zwar sind das
gemahlene haselnüsse wir müssen noch mal
dass nur haselnüsse 200 gramm
da haben wir ein päckchen backpulver so
ein päckchen backpulver gramm ein
päckchen backpulver sich überall
genommen seien 80 gramm 18 kommt das ist
ungefähr so viel wie deine gesamte
hirnmasse mir nicht meinen 18 gramm ja
in dem vakuum drin sorgen weniger
dann haben wir hier sieben
lebkuchengewürz und zwar haben wir
lebkuchen und zwar genau 20 gramm
brauchen wir alles drin lebt lebt noch
kardamom koriander zimt koriander kader
mag es darin
ja
danke tom ja okay dann haben wir noch
mehl und sagen wie viel gramm mehl und
das könnt ihr alles nachlesen auf
blog.de
wenn das herz ich mitbekommen habe also
ich fange mal an
ok als erstes machen wir folgendes dann
immer den top 4
folgt man kurz genießen denn wir sind
top 4 und den topf nehmen haben wir
bereits jetzt machen wir erst die butter
ein wahnsinn
in der zeit wo die butter schmilzt
machen mir hasen müsse dann machen wir
das ja hier macht das jetzt richtig und
fangen wir jetzt hier
und zwar zu australien macht wieder
richtig löschen die produktplatzierung
ja und jetzt die nächste rein
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich nur drehen können
das krieg ich auch noch hinter was wir
sagen ist wie blöd kann man eigentlich
sagen
[Gelächter]
jetzt reden die studie gemacht hat mein
gott ist okay genau jetzt dreht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir die hasen ist
gemahlen richtig gelegt ok jetzt tun mir
die butter schmelzen und jetzt können
wir auch der schon den honig rein machen
und zwar ist ein ganz besonderer honig
nein
ja und zwar ist er ganz besonders
bittersüße das ist eine chronik gemacht
doch ja aber das waren dinge hatten die
gewerkschaft das waren dinge
das war fleißig wie man das auf jeden
fall mal weiter und zwar hat der grüne
hier den honig reingemacht
so und jetzt noch einen teelöffel wandel
extra kein okay das war ein tolles spiel
extra was machen wir jetzt genau jetzt
weiß ich wie hast du das hier rumrich
nehme ich schaue genauer schlage ich die
eier schaumig und zwar tue ich erst mal
das sind dabei noch eine prise salz mit
trend dadurch vorher schon rein gemacht
da durch diese drei glücklichen eier und
macht diese drei glücklichen akteuer
hier rein und dann nehme ich hier ein
roboter oder ein handrührgerät
[Musik]
und es waren jetzt so lange bis es
schaurig ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
private kurzflüge ton genau jetzt ist es
die mutter geschmolzen mit mit mit dem
honig zusammen und jetzt soll's der
bühne das einfach abkühlen mit 200
milliliter milch
jetzt können wir alles zusammen rein
machen doch doch noch was geht
nein glaubt mir dass ich alles sagen ich
hab das schon mal fernsehen gesehen
so jetzt kann ich mich noch mal jetzt
müsse zu einer homogenen masse geehrt
werden die mutter muss auch noch ein ast
die butter vergessen juni doch mal wie
gut auch noch einen geh- wahnsinn weil
meine frau wird es eine viel zu
professionell aus ok jetzt kommen jetzt
mal die jetzt werden wir das weiterhin
zu einer homogenen masse verrühren und
wie gemacht ist
[Musik]
das rein und zwar auch wichtig teamwork
juni ich denke der rahmen der bug rahmen
ist eingestellt auf der richtigen größe
ich denke auch dass der teig nummern
hochgehen wird oder der klage am
backpulver reingemacht
das heißt wir können jetzt auch ein
bisschen breiter machen sagt man doch
zufrieden ja und zwar jetzt den backofen
bei mittlerer schiene und zwar beim
wichtig grad also ich glaube 105 175
grad assist funktion heißt einfach ich
mache den backofen drauf ist ihre ihn
und er macht frei und dann machen wir
das ding rein bei 175 grad
und zwar fünf ungefähr 25 minuten jeder
backofen ist da anders
und dann schauen was rauskommt jetzt
wird es ganz ganz einfach noch zeit
einstellen oder ja und zwar
das riecht schon richtig weihnachtlich
während der kuchen gebacken habe jenny
und ich zusammen aufgeräumt das ist mir
ganz ganz wichtig den arbeitsplatz
sauber zu verlassen
ja und jetzt was man jetzt stäbchen
probe so uns war die stäbchen sind hier
jetzt stecken wir mal ein
da hat jemand seine stäbchen probe
gemacht ich war es nicht jetzt gucken
mal was hängen bleibt ist es okay ich
denke der kuchen ist fertig ja richtig
toll
lebkuchen entschuldigung lebkuchen und
jetzt machen wir ausschneiden
genau dafür den tortenring messer das da
hier ist ein partner sollen backform
messer jetzt kriege ich schon hin
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das mal frei gemacht aber
ich lasse jetzt kuchen erstmal kurz
abkühlen und zwar abkühlen heiße sich
den kühlschrank stellen es wäre falsch
warum was passiert so ein spiel über
warmes im kühlschrank gestellt
wasser wasser denn die hat auch schon
wasser gezogen
so wie man das blech das ist es heißt
nicht anpassen einfach nur abkühlen
lassen
der zwischenzeit könnt ja auch espresso
trinken kaffee ja genau ich mache zum
kaffee und 510 minuten bisschen
abgekühlt hat das wir sind schneller
geht können wir vielleicht auch raus auf
den balkon stellen so anstellen muss
raus jetzt bin ich draußen vorm balkon
und warten mal 10 15 minuten bis der
teig ist der lebkuchen abgekühlt ist
können zu hause auch machen oder
erwartet einfach noch länger aber ich
habe keine zeit wenn wir über müssen
noch die fliesen legen müssen und das
smart werk machen müssen deswegen kurz
herausgestellt dass er abkühlt
genau das ist jetzt abgekühlt und noch
ein bisschen lassmann abkühlt und
währenddessen haben uns entschlossen dem
könig zusammen weil wir ja sehr sehr
wieso ich sagen spontan sind dass wir
über den lebkuchen noch eine schoko sich
drüber machen
das ist doch nicht so dass zur
schokoglasur genau und jetzt was machen
wir als nächstes dann habe ich hier 200
gramm kuvertüre genommen
das macht wildberg ouvertüre 200 gramm
kuvertüre und 20 gramm kokosöl genau
fest oder öl sei egal weil wenn es genau
und jetzt mal folgendes ist nehmen wir
die impf methode so wenig kennst du die
tore schon was davon gehört
du bist auch nicht geben habe ich
rechnen okay dann halt der abstand von
mir weil er es nicht geben das heißt man
immer methode ist ein zwei drittel ein
drittel okay so zwei drittel heißt
mittun zwei drittel erhitzen und wenn
wir uns dann flüssig haben wir zum
abkühlen noch ein drittel fest die
kuvertüre rein damit es auf die perfekte
grad temperatur 28 grad ist glaube ich
unterkühlt damit die schokoglasur glänzt
und nicht so weiß wird richtig okay
jetzt habe folgendes problem und zwar
müssen das ist ein drittel auf teilen
aber wir haben vier steilen so jetzt
fängt matt heran und dann sowas besser
dritteln mach3 keine macht 12
die 2002 jetzt machen wir folgen das
jetzt machen kleinstein bin ich weiß
warum ich das kleinsteinberg was ich
kriege arbeiten und warum steigt das
ding ist klein gar nicht schneller geld
genau richtig genau machst du das noch
ganz kurz klinik schon mal einschalten
genau und zwar erklären ganz kurze lamas
ponys aktionsfeld anschauen so und was
hast du da mussten ab der heißen
wasserbad ist ja das wort aber die
couture okay
[Applaus]
die kunst ist jetzt ganz wichtig das
wasser nicht mit der schokolade in
verbindung zu bringen weil sonst geht
die schokolade kaputt da muss man
richtig dass finger geschildert wir
haben und in den spitzenjahren
fingerspitzengefühl
okay das ist jetzt die impfung methode
und zwar habe ich das klein gehackt und
es tut mir einfach dass da noch
reingehen
ok jetzt gilt es runter auf die perfekte
temperatur und die schokolade die wir
nach hinten lebkuchen ziehen wird so
richtig glänzen und nicht matt weiß
zusätzlich tun wir jetzt noch dieses
kokosöl rheinknie mal das richtig toll
aus jetzt haben das geschmolzen nach der
impfung tode
ich hatte heute auch was gelernt können
jetzt können wir jetzt verteilt wie das
wahnsinn oder wie das hingekriegt habe
jetzt können wir hier drauf genau und
zwar
als geplant ok jetzt muss verschmieren
verspachteln
wir zeigen wir bringen das ein bisschen
action reihe und zwar action
ich habe einfach noch mal ein paar hasen
müsse ganz nicht haselnüsse mandeln und
mandel tue ich jetzt mal mit diesen
tollen nach ihre messer kleine passage
ist einfach so
unter stehe aber nach regionen der arm
oder ich hab ich habe keine hari
unterarm gesorgt
es stelle am körper da wachsen haare
nicht und war ich auf den
handinnenflächen kann ich ihnen genehme
mit dem lang ihre messer vielleicht bin
ich aber eben würde buddhist us tour
verlassen unterarme und handflächen da
gibt es keine haare und dann alles
gedacht du hast irgendwie auf dem
tyrannosaurus rex hat auch so kurze aber
[Gelächter]
wir müssen es die jetzt einschlagen
august ist er jetzt einfach hier ich
zeichne es ganz kurz
ganz ganz einfach hat es schon im
fernsehen gesehen okay das war nicht
sauber
beten ist erschrocken lassen sondern du
vollpfosten sie ist das ding ab ist
[Gelächter]
schnell er ist immer schnell helfen wir
einfach mal alles christoffel und hole
mir irgendjemand da diese dinge probiert
okay wir sagen aber nicht nur das
gemacht haben
[Musik]
das soll jetzt immer fertig und ziemlich
toll aus ich habe es auch schon
angeschnitten
jetzt sagt die ella mal probieren wurde
und die machen wir das auch probieren
sonst soll man die mama her was der kini
und murat gemacht haben jetzt nicht mal
gespannt
ich hatte ja ständig ganz einfach weil
ich einfach nicht wusste ob das
überhaupt hinkriegt habe ich das einfach
so genau
später machen die kleine dekoriert schon
jetzt probier mal biete aber so wirklich
ehrlich ja genau so ist es nicht aus wie
dekubitus mit hatte charakter der zweite
haken hat ja ok probier mal genau heller
lag uns auf folgendes beim hella
lebkuchen habe ja noch nie gesehen
hella liegt mir einfach darauf vergessen
hätte auch daran denken könnte
heute lese da hätte mitglieder oder hast
du kannst kein okay auf jeden fall
wir haben keine vergessenen zeiten
zumeist dunkel gewesen also ich bin
jetzt so richtig lecker werde ich jetzt
ich würde ganz hatte mir was sie
aussagen möchte er seine fotos machen
was ich auch noch vergessen hat zu sagen
ist wir haben es nicht so lang abkühlen
lassen
wir wollen
die platzierung war probieren wir mal
schokokuchen steiner
juni wetter gemacht haben wir gemacht
hat als ich auf mich weil der ixia
außerdem ist andauernd fünf minuten lang
beleidigt beruf aufzuschreiben sagt aber
ich echt cool man ja ja ja abgesehen das
kann nicht jeder machen meint krieges
hinkriegt dann ist es wirklich da kann
es auch euer hund machen und euer
hamster wollte nur sagen es reicht ja
was hast du mit ihm befreundet wir
finden es super lecker
ich habe keine ferien nein ich bin
leider aus dem alter raus und mini der
hat nur frei von seinem bewährungshelfer
deswegen ist er hier also schaut beim
nächsten mal mit faulenzen heißt vorrath
5 minuten kochen und backen auf geringem
bildungsniveau mit blick auf das nein
von zwangsarbeit netz gekauft
pauli
[Musik]